esta manifestación contra la guerra en
ucrania tiene lugar en la capital
italiana
[Música]
miles de personas denuncian los horrores
del conflicto por el precio de la
energía también es una de las
principales preocupaciones
y última factura de gas fue de 170 euros
y la que recibía este mes es de 270
euros son 100 euros más es un gran golpe
para nosotros
es preocupante que prácticamente
dependemos de un solo proveedor tenemos
que diversificar nuestras fuentes de
abastecimiento energético
el gobierno italiano y toda la unión
europea desean diversificar el
suministro de energía
rusia es el mayor proveedor de gas de la
unión europea representa el 40 por
ciento de sus importaciones sin embargo
italia ya recurre a otros países
argelia le suministra actualmente el 25
por ciento de su consumo está en los
países del golfo al otro lado del
mediterráneo pero las importaciones
están sujetas a las leyes del mercado
qatar qatar es el mayor productor
mundial de gas natural licuado
y vende este gas natural licuado al
mayor importador de competición
está claro que casi italia y de aumentar
los volúmenes qatar puede pedir una
contrapartida para desviar parte de su
gas son dinámicas comerciales pero todo
esto se hace en el marco de acuerdos
políticos sobre estados
de los 27 estados de la unión europea
alemania es el país que más depende de
la energía rusa más del 50 por ciento de
su gas y más del 75% de su petróleo
crudo proceden de rusia
esta fábrica de brandenburgo produce
baldosas de cerámica
y la única fuente de energía es el gas
cada año se consumen entre 12 y 13
millones de metros cúbicos de gas
aquí todo el gas utilizado proviene de
rusia
por lo tanto detener las importaciones
sería un duro golpe para la producción
para nosotros esto sería obviamente un
gran riesgo porque se alemania decide
racionar el gas no será ciertamente para
dárselo a la producción de baldosas
para las empresas y el gobierno alemán
es esta dependencia es cada vez menos
aceptable precisamente en esta región
rica en carbono la industria reclama una
revisión urgente de la estrategia
energética alemana
y
habíamos decidido salir del átomo y del
carbón pero debemos reconsiderar estas
decisiones y preguntarnos si no ponen en
peligro la economía alemana nuestras
necesidades energéticas podemos ver
estos días lo dependientes que somos
frenar a alemania a su transición
energética para ganar más margen de
maniobra no es tan seguro
berlín los activistas contra la energía
nuclear se oponen fuertemente
esto es absurdo completamente absurdo
creo que deberíamos dedicar todos
nuestros esfuerzos a la energía solar y
eólica
y no a la nuclear ni al gas
y no solo en alemania se plantean estas
problemáticas
en groninga en los países bajos se
encuentra uno de los mayores yacimientos
de gas de europa pero la explotación del
suelo debía detenerse este año porque
provocan numerosos terremotos
durante uno de los traslados esta puerta
no quería abrirse cuando yo quería salir
porque oía que las puertas crujía tan
fuerte que sentía
desde el inicio de la guerra en ucrania
reina está preocupada
si peligra el suministro de gas ruso
podría aplazarse el cierre de la planta
de groninga
es una forma de compromiso que tiene que
hacer la sociedad de países bajos
aumentamos la producción en groninga
para depender menos de rusia
pero asumimos el riesgo de generar más
terremotos
todavía quedan por explotar 450.000
millones de metros cúbicos de gas aquí
un depósito potencial que europa podría
considerar en los próximos meses